this week on the climate show how do we
get our cities to move from this lighted
by congestion cursed by pollution and
worsening climate change to this a
cleaner calmer healthier city which is
actually easy to get around
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the climate show
and this week we're all about cities
their congestion and their traffic how
do we make them more climate friendly in
the future and I've come to Oxford
because this is one of the places on the
front line of this argument
I'll also be traveling to a city in
Belgium where they've managed to
Dethrone the car as king and claim
they've got a much more pleasant
environment as a result
we'll also be in London to hear how
plans for cleaner air are pitting the
mare against many motorists
and go to Wales where the Welsh
government is taking radical action and
scrapping nearly all of its Road
building plans
but first here in the city of dreaming
spiers the row over Rhodes has turned
almost as toxic as the air the
councilors want to clean
in the ancient city of Oxford people and
goods are struggling to move around
freely while the council makes plans
businesses are already adapting
Jake used to deliver with diesel Vans
but became uneasy with their pollution
and so did some of his customers
which takes me back I used to be a cycle
career when I was a student
and I joined him on a delivery round
many cities suffer from similar
transport woes to Oxford gridlock
pollution climate worries with a
population that continues to grow and
doesn't get enough exercise bath
Cambridge Bristol Newcastle and
Edinburgh are all grappling for a
solution and share a common enemy the
car less of these diesel vehicles less
vehicles within the city I've owned this
business with my business partner we
both have young children who grew up in
this city and will continue to grow up
in this city and we want them to be safe
we want them to breathe clean air and we
want them to have a clean and positive
future it really is as simple as trying
to make it a more pleasant place to live
the oxygen plan divides the city into
six zones each Zone will have a filter
road that means you won't be able to
drive from Zone to Zone but walk cycle
or take public transport
drivers will have to go out to the Ring
Road round and back in again however
residents will get a hundred passes a
year to cut through the zones and there
are exemptions for example blue badge
holders carers and Community nurses can
drive freely and these aren't the first
restrictions on motorist Freedom the
council does have a bit of previous
low traffic neighborhoods are already in
place in some parts of Oxford like here
around the Cowley Road they restrict the
freedom of movement of drivers and many
businesses along here think it restricts
their profits too this is one of them
Cocos
the trouble is is that people just
aren't bothering to come anymore no car
parking they can't stop and click their
goods from certain specialist food shops
that are up the road delivery drivers
can't get around to get the thing taxi
drivers don't want to come and people
fixing your the plumber electricians
they're not wanting to come because it
takes them too long and they've got
nowhere to park you'd agree climate
change is the problem yep pollution's a
problem yep I completely agree but
unfortunately you have to work these
things through properly they haven't
they've just blanketly done it this is
actually one of the most polluted spots
in Oxford the plan supporters have done
opinion polls and studied Council
election results I think the opposition
is loud rather than why it's bad we did
a yougov poll which was representative
across age groups and across like you
know political bias and all kinds of
things and two to one people are in
favor of low traffic neighborhoods and
two to one people are in favor of
traffic filters and in the last local
elections a set of candidates stood on
specifically an anti-local low traffic
neighborhood policy and none of them won
apart from one who's already an
incumbent and change policy so when it
comes down to actual democracy and how
people vote people are consistently
voting for parties who who choose this
let's go to a city that has been through
all this and supporters say shows us a
desirable future
this is the Belgian city of Ghent
population half a million and it looks
like a good chunk of their transport is
right here
six years ago they introduced their
traffic or circulation plan which
somewhat like Oxford restricted car
access to the city center and between
residential neighborhoods the effect has
been dramatic
well and traffic free it hardly feels
like you're in a city center yet this is
one of the main Junctions
it's extraordinarily calm
I caught up with the architect of this
plan in the saddle of course this is how
a city should be
space many people walking people cycling
people are enjoying the city that's uh
why we did it we gave the road to the
cyclists and so we gave the former
psychopath to the pedestrians and so
more space for pedestrians more space
for cyclists fewer cars demand fewer
places to leave them this was a car park
it's now a park complete with built-in
trampoline and a little further on they
freed the water so what's the name of
this River this is the the best guy this
is the Bava Bridge there was a river but
it was underground and on the surface
there was a parking spot just cars and
what we did after circulation because we
didn't need that parking spot anymore we
opened the river again
and so you see it became one of the most
beautiful places here in here in Ghent
and it is so quiet here isn't it I mean
it's a really Pleasant place to be
before there were traffic jams
everywhere that jam is gone doesn't
exist anymore at that moment the city
became more friendly for people and that
was the purpose
but the process was far from friendly
many people love their cars and others
need the business they bring challenge
that at your peril it was a period of
death threats of insults the death
threats for you death threats for me
yeah for me and my family and and so I
had six weeks of police surveillance was
not pleasant at all it was very rough
difficult but it was worth it a few
years on and tempers may have cooled but
it's not a city entirely of converts we
come in in the city from 6 till 11.
that's a problem because there were a
lot of people in the restaurants we have
to deliver early in the morning but it
doesn't make it much easier for you to
get around oh no no no no we have a lot
of clients and we have to deliver on
certain hours so it's not it's not easy
it's full of bicycles eh they don't have
lights they they drive without arms they
are on the phone
yeah
yeah I think it's a good thing that
there are not too much cars and it's
better for children that there are not
too much cars inside the city centers in
the years since the plan came in Walking
has increased and cycling has doubled
but buses and trams have benefited too
public transport usage has gone up about
12 as they brought in this plan you can
see how busy it is and because there are
fewer cars on the road the trams can get
around faster
hey you know a lot of friends on the
street here yeah I know many people here
Philippe insists the opposition against
travel plans was loud but small and his
re-election tends to back that up
is that echoed back in Oxford where some
traffic blocking bollards have been
ripped up and wild conspiracy theories
take root
regime change is often brutal not least
taking the crown from the car
you may think this place in Belgium can
teach us something but our own capital
city was a Pioneer in taking on the car
introducing a congestion charge almost
exactly 20 years ago and now the
anti-pollution Fight Continues with an
attempt to expand the ultra low emission
zone so does the Furious pushback his
Skies Saba Chaudhary
beautiful you can take a photo of me
Ella was a happy healthy child until she
developed the chronic asthma that led to
her untimely death
she made history the first person in the
UK with air pollution listed as their
cause of death now ten years on her
mother's working to clean the toxic air
that took her daughter's life what the
coroner did you say without the air
pollution Not only would Allah not have
got asthma but on the night she died it
was the highest it had ever been until
then I think she'll be quite surprised
at why she died and how many people are
impacted because she loved the air she
wanted to be a pilot so I don't know how
she would have taken that that the year
that she loved so much ultimately is
what killed her
Rosamond hopes the expansion of London's
ultra low emission Zone known as Euless
will limit the number of old polluting
cars entering the capital through
deterrence
a 12 pound fifty daily charge to drive
inside and a fine for those who won't
pay
currently you less covers inner London
from the end of August it will include
all boroughs most areas are largely in
favor of the expansion some are on the
fence and want it delayed but others are
actively hostile and campaigning against
it and this is an exclusive to London
several cities across the UK also have
clean air zones
and it seems to be working research
shows pollution levels are more than 20
percent lower than they would have been
without Euless despite this Heathrow
shift worker Tina still has strong
reservations driving this old diesel car
to work will cost her an additional 4
000 pounds a year making the Night Bus
her only affordable option yes you're
working but it's like everything's gone
up the cost of living has gone up gas
electric food it's like where are we
going to find this extra money from
that's the main thing is we don't have
the finances Tina says Euless is a tax
on the poor but for the mayor of London
that's not the case how are people
supposed to afford that during the cost
of living crisis it's a bold move to
introduce uh Euless expansion at this
particular juncture don't you think well
I understand the challenges people are
facing as a consequence of the
government's policies that's why we've
announced the biggest Scrappy scheme in
history it's the poorest londoners
breathing the worst of this pollution
those who are driving gluten vehicles
are breeding in the poison your kids in
the back breathing in Poison I think the
the choice is this we can be the first
generation to take action or the last
generation not to
whether the mayor gets his wish or not
it'll come too late for Ella whose mum
will keep fighting the rights of
children to breathe cleaner air Saba
Chowdhury Sky News
although drivers of electric cars will
be free to use London's ultra low
emission Zone here in Ghent they'll face
much the same restrictions as other cars
and we had an interesting question about
EVS from Nick who tweeted to ask me how
long will it be before someone admits
that electric cars won't save the planet
as there isn't enough of the rare earth
minerals needed for everyone to make the
switch
well is that true
it's very much for your question
right for
eign
the really important point is that
there's no shortage of these in the
Earth's crust we know where many of
those mineral deposits are now ideally
we'd get those minerals from recycling
but right now there's not a lot of
electric vehicles there to recycle so
we're going to have to mine and of
course mining has to be done responsibly
we have to minimize environmental
impacts we have to ensure that the
communities around are not suffering
adverse impacts all those kinds of
things and that takes time and that is
the challenge making sure we can do that
mining as quickly as possible but as
responsibly as possible
and if you have a question you'd like us
to try and answer on the program scan
the QR code on your screen right now
after the break World leading or economy
wrecking we'll hear how the Welsh
government has scrapped almost all of
its major road building schemes
and we'll meet Kamala Omar The Tick Tock
star time to inspire more women to take
the two wheels
[Music]
welcome back again to a city that's been
touted as a future Urban Paradise if
only we could swap our four wheels for
two or maybe even two legs but choices
like that are so much easier to say than
do the decisions we've made over where
we live where we socialize where we work
even where we educate our children have
been taken with transport quite probably
driving in mind and threatening that
provokes well something like road rage
the Welsh government has taken a bold
approach stop building them largely
altogether
[Applause]
putting the brakes on carbon emissions
and steering towards a less car-centric
future
that was the message from the Welsh
government as they announced they were
delaying changing or scrapping nearly
all major road projects planned in the
country around the world countries have
discovered that adding Lanes just
creates more traffic
in Wales we can do it differently
59 Road building schemes had been on
hold while a review was carried out to
see if they were compatible with the
country's climate change targets
but this week the labor government in
Cardiff declared that only 15 would go
ahead as planned the rest dropped
amended or scaled back look at the Stock
Building roads but we're going to build
different types of Roads so we could
have roads for bus space active travel
space and uh for cast members and we're
investing in Alternatives you can have
some angry motorists in Wales
well the problem is the debate around
transport has been
labeled instantly as being anti-carn
most politicians therefore run a mile
but I think given the science is getting
harder and harder on climate change
we're just gonna have to face up to it
because if we don't make the changes
we'll keep getting into a worse
situation while environmental groups
call the policy change World leading the
conservative opposition in the Senate
expressed concern that it would limit
growth
Deputy Minister Rhodes might be these
awful stretches of concrete but to us
businesses commuters and residents they
are a necessity we need adequate rows to
run a top quality public transport
Network to help businesses Thrive and to
get the economy firing on all cylinders
are just some of the few reasons why I
speak so passionately about this
so another front of what some see is an
emerging transport culture War without a
quick Victory one thing is certain
turning around the oil tanker of
car-based infrastructure will not be
easy
now as you might be able to see I'm in
London Chiswick to be precise and this
place has had its own row over Street
space with this cycle Lane here behind
me and I'm with two people who are very
at home in the urban jungle that's
Valentin kineo from the center for
City's Think Tank and Tanya Braun from
the charity living Street which
campaigns for better pedestrian
infrastructure Valentin why are these
changes so difficult so hot if you like
I think that's because Behavior change
you know takes time and you know the
reason why changing our attitudes to
driving you know me has to do with the
fact that cars still are the main mode
of Transport in most Journeys even in
London are still made by a car so you
know switching from one mode of
transport to another is is a difficult
move for many people
people really love their cars don't they
Tanya it's difficult to get them out of
them I mean yeah we've been building our
City's towns neighborhoods around cars
since the 1960s and so it yeah they
dominate our everyday lives
um but walking really is the the easiest
most sustainable form of transport and
so I think these measures are are really
going to help us to turn around the the
issues that cars are causing through air
pollution and inactivity anything to do
with transport actually affects so much
to do with our lives not least business
Valentine how do how do we think
businesses could be affected by this
move too if you like Karma more tranquil
cities so it's often a concerned that's
Rave businesses themselves in terms of
you know the impact that these schemes
will have on their activity we've looked
at the evidence from a number of schemes
whether that's in central London or in
places like Birmingham that have
introduced Canal zones and looking at
footfall and spending that doesn't show
any evidence that it has had a clear
impact you know bad impact
a good one well it kind of same same
really I think what we're seeing is that
essentially you know in places where
either we have more cycle Lanes or you
have more pedestrian High streets then
people tend to spend more time in the
area because it's just a nicer place to
be around and so they tend to spend not
just more time but also more money in
there so actually the evidence shows
that it's quite positive for businesses
to do to have those skis and living
streets to start a pedestrian pound
report looking at uh walking on the High
Street we've actually found that and
when there are more walking Journeys
made 40
um more money is spent in the area right
so it could be the savior of the High
Street it could be the Savior at the
High Street
that's quite a a bold sales pitch
because certainly as I say in the short
term businesses mainly seem to be
worried and when we spoke to a guy in
Oxford who said look if people can't
drive in here from out of town my
restaurant's dead I mean he has maybe
got a point hasn't he
time and we shouldn't necessarily assess
the impact of these schemes you know in
the first six or 12 months because it
does take some people to actually make a
change now I think it's very important
to make sure that people who don't live
in the city centers can still access the
central over town I'm going to interrupt
you because it's kind of relevant I mean
the noise that's around us here
illustrates that they aren't necessarily
particularly Pleasant places and they
could be much more pleasant couldn't
they tell you they really could I mean
and it quieter safer roads bring more
people out and I think more people out
is a nicer place to be I mean it's it
can be really small things that
encourage people to ditch the car and
walk instead such as slower speeds on
our roads
um clearer Pavements nicer Pavements
um and and yeah just more people more
people around Yeah because sometimes
it's about residential areas as well
isn't it and and and and moving through
those what do you think that the sort of
city of the future will will or should
look like Valentine well it should be a
city with your cars but back to your
point you're seeing change not just in
London but across the UK you know five
years ago barely any City in UK had a
penis zone or a low Mission zone now I
think we have six and more more to come
so that's that's a positive change and
the City of the future will be a city
where you know we have less toxic air
toxic air is extremely harmful for human
health and should be dealt with so you
know more pedestrian areas fewer cars
more people uh traveling whether that's
the commute or for leisure using active
travel
Valentine Tanya thank you both very much
indeed now I want to introduce you to a
woman who's taken to social media to try
and encourage more women to take to the
saddle
foreign
I'm a teacher assistant working in the
primary school
cycling something I've always been into
since I was a little girl but I took it
really serious since Kobe started
I've asked around everybody that I knew
if they had a spare bike in their houses
and then my older brother came to the
house with a Brompton that's when the
adventure began really
well I'm gonna buy a kit so good for you
especially for your mental health and
well-being I mean I know it's helped me
a lot from young age to old age it's
just it's for everyone really I mean one
of the reasons why I use social media is
just to show everyone that it's okay for
me for women like me as a Muslim woman
wearing the headscarf and the whole bio
that is all right to cycle
cycle around
last year I took part in the Queen's
Platinum Jubilee
I got to ride my bike around the mouth
it was such an amazing experience to see
everybody you know cheering for us and
cycling around it was just amazing
[Music]
I know growing up in London that cycle
Lane has changed a lot there are more
Cyclones that we ever had before we've
definitely build up a lot of women and
other cyclists they're confident to
cycle on the roads
[Music]
now before we go a reminder that you can
catch the daily climate show on Sky News
that's at 3 30 p.m on weekdays and you
can get all the latest climate and
environmental news on the Sky News app
and website or by scanning the QR code
on your screen right now
for this week next week I'm going to be
under these streets in London
and into our sea who said TV wasn't
glamorous see you then
[Music]